no one is safe hanging out in Washington Square park
I literally just like here making a little TikTok
and this guy comes up to me and he's like
can I sing to you
and I was like
yeah mind you
the camera in my face
I like I don't know what's happening
he was really great
phenomenal singer
very very good
I am just
what are you supposed to do when someone is singing at you
with a camera in your face
like I was like laughing
I didn't
I don't know how to react and I am like so anxious about how it’s gonna be perceived
also like
I'm wearing like literally this I'm
I don't look good right now
like I just came back from staten island
I haven't slept I look a mess
and I'm so anxious because he showed me his profile after and he has 250,000 followers
so if this gets the wrong side of the internet
they're going to tear me alive
so I'm just telling you now
fair warning people might be mean to me
people are watching me make this
people might be mean to me on the internet
I was he was good
I liked him I wasn’t trying to be mean
I clarified with him
me and him slay cool good
please don't be mean to me
I just don't know how to act when
when someone puts a camera in my face
cause like if I put a camera in my face
it's fine but when someone else puts camera on my face
not good also like
I'm not wearing a bra
so I couldn't even cover
oh my god
it's probably out there guys
I'm so anxious
I'm so
I'm preparing for myself mentally for the fatphobic comments on that video
maybe he doesn't even post it
maybe it's fine
maybe he doesn't post it as fine wish me luck